bord de mer et qu'on retrouve philippe
labro à cannes bordeaux nerfs oui mais
cannes n'est pas détaché du monde
extérieur la preuve c'est que derrière
vous a peut-être vu des pancartes des
banderoles des panneaux il s'agit d'un
certain de manifestants qui protestent
contre l'actuel régime gouvernement turc
et qui réclame la libération des
prisonniers dans les prisons turques et
qui protestent donc contre l'intolérance
or l'intolérance ettore scola vous la
traitez d'une certaine façon dans la
nuit de varennes le premier film
officiellement compétition aujourd'hui
et qui sera aussi à paris et qui sort en
ce moment un appareil que je bascule en
tolérance soit le club l'a nommé de
quelconque idée de compiler au logis de
france ou du manichéisme
donc c'est pour ça que dans la nuit deux
bars et j'essaie de
de comprendre peut-être encore mieux
ceux qui regrettent le passé ce qu'ils
apprécient pas tellement le mot nouveau
qui va arriver en plus besoin et je
crois que notre confrère il tandis que
la votre film en ce moment même et
visionnée par les critiques les
journalistes et les membres du jury
ça n'explique pas les raisons pour
lesquelles vous suez autant c'est que je
crois qu'en porter ou d'une grippe
difficile vous n'êtes pas membre ennjimi
fils
nous allons parler si vous voulez bien
de la nuit de varennes dans un instant
mais je rappelle que l'événement hier
soir en dehors de l'ouverture du
festival c'était le la reprise à
projection d'un monument de l'histoire
du cinéma il s'agissait d'un tolérance
de l'américain griffiths un film qui
date de 1916 qui dure deux heures
cinquante qui a donc 66 ans aujourd'hui
un film maudit que peu de gens en fait
avait vu et dont nous allons vous
présenter un extrait
car d'une certaine façon le festival
hier soir a été comme une espèce de
grande cinémathèque
ils ont extrait qu'on va voir montrer
nouveauté c'était le premier à venir
jean cyr un décor fait agresser en 1916
puis on en a usé et abusé
oui
bien entendu il s'agit d'un film muet
mais hier les organisateurs du festival
avaient france roche se trouver une
façon de rendre les choses un peu plus
vivante
il avait déniché un pianiste qui a l'âge
du film en fait et même plus que l'âge
du film et qui pendant toute la
projection comme à la grande époque du
cinéma muet à accompagner le film sur
son piano ce qui était une autre
performance volker schlöndorff c'était
votre première vision de l'intolérance
non je n'avais vu évidemment il ya plus
de vingt ans à la cinémathèque mettant
toutes sortes forme
estropiés et surtout jamais avec une
telle qualité de projection et de copie
et surtout jamais avec une audience de
deux mille ou plus de personnes dans la
salle et ça c'était la grande expérience
comme en compte ce film d'abord n'a pas
du tout vieilli pour nous tous que nous
avons rencontré a l'impression que nous
faisons un cinéma un peu sclérosé quand
on voit ça puisque griffiths il a il a
réussi ce qu'on nous réclame toujours et
ça dès 1916 c'est à dire d'aller à la
fois le grand spectacle comme d'y
retourner
le cinéma en tant que fête foraine et
cirque et d'autre part ils traitent de
l'intolérance l'intolérance contre
laquelle on est en train de manifester
la ici derrière nous pour l'écrasement
du peuple turc intolérance aussi parfois
même dans la programmation des films
puisque j'entends beaucoup parler
d'ettore scola et je ne veux pas lui
casser son coup mais il ya un deuxième
film qui passe aujourd'hui au festival
qui n'a pas été mentionnée qui justement
un film turc
nous allons en parler d'un autre qui ont
souvent prises dont nous avons même
l'interview de cet auteur alors là on
peut laisser le journal se dérouler
jusqu'au bout volker schlöndorff vous
étiez là aussi parce que vous avez une
palme d'or pour le tambour vous êtes
donc un des grands anciens du festival
et vous avez reçu aussi un trophée
parmi les dix ou douze metteurs en scène
qui ont été hier honoré dans cette
ouverture de festival
un dernier mot pour vous depuis 66 ans
depuis intolérance le cinéma n'a pas
évolué n'a pas changé les faits c'est
aussi moderne
vous n'avez rien inventé non non nous on
n'a vraiment rien à inventer c'est ça
qui est formidable au moment où le
cinéma apparu
toutes les possibilités ont été
exploités et après on a essayé de nous
fixer comment dire par les canaux
industriels sur certains domaines et je
suis bien là d'un colloque ou trente
réalisateurs du monde entier ont
participé et tous nous avons dit voilà
il faut retrouver la liberté qu'il y
avait du temps de griffiths c'est à dire
avec le cinéma on peut tout faire et
surtout on peut tout y faire entrer
aussi bien le monde extérieur que le
monde intérieur ça peut être intimiste
ça peut être les grands spectacles tout
est possible merci beaucoup volker
schlöndorff
on peut tout faire avec le cinéma et on
peut tout y faire entrer ettore scola
on peut tout faire avec le cinéma on
peut tout il fait rentrer vient de nous
dire votre collègue votre confrère
volker schlöndorff
qu'avez vous fait entrer dans la nuit de
varennes qu'avez vous voulu mettre dans
la nuit de varennes reconstitution
historique bien sûr qui dure 2h30 je
crois avec de très nombreux comédiens
jean-louis barrault à nos côtés bien sûr
mais il ya daniel gélin
il ya un hachis bull à celle qui collige
emploi brialy marcello mastroianni il
n'est pas encore présent à cannes mais
qui arrive je crois en arts l'histoire
la nuit de varennes
avec tout le respect pour l'histoire que
nous tous
ah bon j'ai aussi un conseiller
historique qui m'a seront donc il faut
respecter l'histoire mais et je crois
qu'il ya très peu d'histoire dans fille
qu'est ce qui nous intéressait et je
pense qu'aulas essaie de mettre dedans
c'est quelque chose sur l'histoire de
l'individu qui changent jamais qui est
une histoire donc aujourd'hui c'est pour
ça que je vais je vais tourner tout à
fait comme celle ci n'était pas habillé
en question si les décors étaient
normales c'est comme si la carrosserie
en bagnole et serge que l'accord donc on
le voit comme le de ça après cinq
minutes pour s'habituer à aimants
d'autres d'autrefois d'autres temps on
est dedans comme dans une histoire
d'aujourd'hui car sont plus qu il soit
plus que les grands événements
c'est l'histoire des hommes de caractère
d'élèves individuelle qui est
au sol ou d'ouvrir source précisant du
même françois la nuit de varennes ça
signifie pour que ce qui bien sûr ne
savent pas et sont pas si nombreux que
cela la fameuse nuit au cours de la
saison alors ceci est le livre le film
catherine rioual connaissant ramsay a
écrit après vous bien sûr le récit
d'après votre fille mais c'est une
habitude française de faire des livres
très passionnant française soir à la
salle catry ghiwane avec la fiche du
film avec le titre du film est écrit par
une autre je vois pas le nombre de ses
amis d ici quelques alors oui
effectivement pas ya écrit qu'au moins
là dessus ce sont vos pour amateurs
vous assurez s'imaginent qu'il ya un
accord entre vos producteurs et les
télés et les éditeurs voici d'ailleurs
sur le zoo a wish i do i am rich des
auteurs mais vous avez raison de dire
que le scénariste de se financer
culturel je trouve c'est vous et ses
adieux à midi et que vous avez un
conseiller historique s'appelle claude
manceron française ils ont tout même de
dire que la nuit de varennes c'est la
nuit au cours de laquelle le roi a fui
en france
la nuit la révolution mais cette nuit ne
raconte pas la fuite du roi elle raconte
ce qui se passe dans une diligence
respecte au risque aulas qui précède qui
s'essuie qui suit celle du roi mais en
fait c'est une sorte de western
historique pour moi parce que d'abord il
appelait la diligence comme danseuse
coach john ford et l'a mis dedans des
représentants de toutes les classes de
la société la classe qui va disparaître
et celle qui est à l'aube d'un monde
nouveau
et parmi ces personnages il était très
très équilibrée parce que les
aristocrates ont quand même ne rendre un
hommage à leurs qualités à leur élégance
par exemple la machine ou là qui
complète et en même temps on sent qu'il
aime
rétif de la bretonne qui est lui qui est
à l'affût des changements de la société
et puis il ya aussi casanova glissant et
dans ceux qui me 15,9 à qui en a assez
des femmes et qu'il refuse est trompé
par mac pro green à s'emmerder
qui a une sorte qu'on se bat au rythme
mais biologique souvent car ils avaient
beau temps où il était jeune
voici un extrait de la nuit par andy
d'ettore scola
et puis j'ai contrôlé par l est aussi
grave qui sont sûres comme ça il a tous
les défauts et toute la colère du
serviteur qui a mis son maître le
déteste et un ep ya un moment où il
chante je veux devenir gentilhomme je ne
veux plus le revivre
c'est le rêve impossible de tous les
serviteurs de tous les temps je
comprends que vous n'êtes pas d'accord
avec tout ce qui s'est passé en france
et 10 89 peut-être vais-je me déplaire à
certains d'entre vous mais je dirais non
je ne suis pas d'accord parce que tout
ici c'est simple et lisible saskin écho
chez les domestiques se sentent
autorisés et présenter un ensemble
est ce que je regrette abel et de
souffrance d'autrui tout celui d'une
grande harmonie où il faisait bon vivre
pour une étrangère aussi la dignité
était respectée la dignité et la
première chose que l'on perde
vous vous préparez à voir le peuple
comme sous verrière et bien c'est le
plus brutal et le plus ironique de
souvent syfy je vous interdit de parler
comme vous le faite c'est à vous
monsieur que je m'adresse à vous
monsieur k d'annaba où madame carnaval
c'est bien moi je vous dirai merci oui
parce que vous m'avez démontré que
j'avais raison de pas venir ici
la vieille france personne avec une
telle insolence mémoire est interdit de
parler
écoutez je n'ose vous ne devez interdire
les facs n'utilisent leur société ces
paroles aussi peut être nuisible
peut-être mais les interdire est
toujours un pas vers la tyrannie et peut
être beau garçon mais quelqu'un perd 1
bologne les épaisses d'allégations la
jeune fille charmante pas mal peut-être
un peu sombre non si bon dieu les a fait
noir il doit y avoir une raison la nuit
de varennes donc premier extrait mais
dans cette rue de varenne une diligence
joue un rôle très important vous le
disiez france rocher un instant la
diligence dans laquelle vous avez mis
les passages ettore scola parmi lesquels
jean louis barrault qui incarne le
célèbre écrivain rétif de la bretonne
oui madame à bangkok
mais forts se passe en suisse je sais
que s'enferme oui c'est un lieu où a
lieu symbolique où
on peut faire un coup dur des caractères
ou ayant le temps les gens se révèlent
parce qu'ils n'ont qu'une chose à faire
c'est d'échanger revivez la rouille le
voyage des plus longs le film est
vraiment alors on a le temps de
rencontrer donc cette ce personnage
incarné par jean louis barrault qui ont
vraiment merveilleux avec le mari dans
le même lit qui ronflait à côté un nom
aux puits dans un confessionnal dans
l'ancien couvent du parc au milieu d'un
flat sur un arbre dans une étable avec
la fiq qui tenait la laine à sa mère
avec qui on faisait un écheveau quoi
vous n'allez pas vous laisser décourager
par une voiture voyant puisque vous
m'avez lu vous savez que je me suis
jamais consacrée à ce genre de femme qui
voyage est en carrosse alors comment
feriez-vous chevalier construire
monsieur rendait peut-être
après un échange des regards aux relevés
pas souvent maintenant prochain relais y
aura les maris vous le faire ici dans la
voiture nous pourrions peut-être
attendre que la nuit tombe et en voyage
dans le noir mais non voyage sera fini
avant que la nuit tombe
au mieux on pourrait tirer le rideau
je ne trouve pas ce jeu faire l'amour
dans un carrosse une lampe peut-être
déjà fait vous dans la plus secrète
alcôves c'est la même chose ce qui est
important c
chaque année
sequedin à mouiller
qui est
piliers
pourquoi
le mystère
sur les barreaux ettore scola vous à
diriger c'est la première fois au fait
du cinéma depuis dix ans plus cher bayti
16 ans pour qu'un problème de retour
derrière les caméras pour autant fait
autant diriger la dernière la caméra au
nom parce que j'aime la profession du
côté professionnel et je crois que pour
être derrière une caméra et vous
connaître sa profession de partir de
l'amateurisme refuserait pas vous permet
dans cette carriole comme ça avec gorges
les liens pendant très longtemps et
j'étais très agréable et puis il savait
quand on a l'habitude de mettre en scène
des acteurs on est très heureux d'obéir
et moi j'étais très heureux d'obéir à
épurer scola d'heure sa sensibilité
correspondait tellement avec la
sensibilité d'une personnage que j'avais
un carnet rétif de la bretonne
il ya ce désir de justice
d'humanité cette sensibilité extrême de
rester juste non pas par exemple
rectif dit je ne plains pâlissait j'ai
trop peu connu les rois que les rois
s'apitoie sur le sort des rois mais je
donne des larmes un homme malheureux
tout à fait dans la sensibilité d'ettore
scola vous entendiez il ya un instant
pendant que jean louis barrault par les
quelques champs derrière nous il se
trouve en effet nous l'avons dit au
cours de ce journal que la vie ne
s'arrête pas avec le cinéma cannes et
que la vie la politique les
manifestations sont aussi présentés
parfois même les manifestants se servent
d'une présence extraordinaire de 2500
journalistes sur la croisette pour
parler des problèmes qui les concernent
il s'agit de manifestants turcs et ils
protestent contre l'incarcération d'un
certain nombre de militants et de
syndiqués turque en turquie et contre le
gouvernement turc or il se trouve que
cinéma rejoins complètement l'actualité
puisque france roche en compétition
aujourd'hui avec bien sûr le pin étant
hezbollah il y à notre film un film turc
oui et ce film turc a été fait par un
metteur en scène condamnés à s'entendre
présenté en a d'ailleurs fait plusieurs
années qu'ils s'appellent images d'une
heure et qui s'est évadé il n'est
environ un an
et il passe d'une est poursuivie par
interpol donc en principe ils se cachent
or aujourd'hui il est arrivé à cannes
pour la présentation de son film et je
l'avais rencontré il ya deux jours à
paris et je lui ai demandé si ce n'était
pas quand même un peu dangereux pour lui
d'être à cannes et sylvie un bras et
voilà ce qu'il m'a répondu écoutez
l'interview de ce metteur en scène
turque
alors que nous entendons les
manifestants autour de cela est-ce que
c'est pas dangereux
telli killed in et aux jets celle que
quand on a envie de faire des choses est
difficile difficile va de pair avec
tanger de toute façon vous avez fait des
choses très difficiles comme par exemple
diriger votre film de la prison
comment faisiez-vous pour expliquer à
ceux qui travaillaient en votre nom
la manière dont vous concevez votre film
et dont vous vouliez le voir tourner
2010 ces films des musiques originales
de l'accouchement d'ailleurs filmé
vu sur la natation fina s'étant évadé de
turquie fin 80 il a pu terminer le film
techniquement en allemagne mais pour ce
metteur en scène qui réalisait ses films
en prison la liberté est une
condamnation ne plus tourner être en
studio chaque jour équivaudrait à une
arrestation car il est fiché par
interpol anticyclique les jeunes et les
régions aucune ilic tennis visées sur
les g7 a remonté de cela et le rock
business unit
alors donc un extrait de ce second film
officiellement en compétition
aujourd'hui à cannes pour la première
journée officielle de projection violent
film turc donc france roche dont vous
avez interviewé le mettant en scène et
ettore scola lui même aussi en
compétition avec la nuit de varennes
mais ettore scola
c'est vraiment pas votre première
présence à cannes maintenant vous avez
fait énormément de très beaux films nous
nous souvenons tous de lui nous sommes
tentés née d'une journée particulière de
bons sales et méchants aux bêtes sales
et méchants affreux sales et méchants et
vous avez déjà été abondamment prix mais
si je me trompe sauf la panne vous
n'avez jamais eu la palme d'or alors
quand vous venez ici
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
vous risquez beaucoup vous avez tout à
gagner et tout à perdre celui-là pas
pour la palme elle a en plus je crois
qu'on peut pas donner et on parlera
quelqu'un qui a été déjà six voix assez
à votre table à l'arrivée à part la
nouveauté il n'ya pas l'arrivée de
quelqu'un mais cette fois et partout le
même important pour moi que j'ai été ici
avec beaucoup de films mais que beaucoup
d'acteurs b&g jamais été ici avec un
acteur comme jaloux et barreaux je
m'étais ici avec un sujet comme la nuit
de varennes
oui à reebok
je fais un film par et ce film sont
finies dans le mois d'avril
ce n'est pas par hasard je calcule pas
mettant sur chalmé ça arrive tu jouer et
donc je passe d'être ici aussi l'année
prochaine et pour l'année prochaine si
je peux me permettre à cette solution de
souhaiter un par année vous apporte dans
les zones scolaires
car effectivement là seulement ici le
soleil commence à être assez éprouvant
pour nos participants enfants je suis
une dernière question mais jusqu'aux
larmes monsieur baroin fut rendu
l'antenne
moi je voudrais savoir mme baron a
ressenti quand il est revenu dans un
studio pour la première fois après
beaucoup de temps passé seulement au
théâtre comme si j'étais allé la veille
charlotte je peux le dire devenir
quelqu'un je lutte comme tous les
gravats
modeste elle est
le cas de prendre
région exigeait que le premier jour et
la première scène qu'il retournait
c'était excellent traité compliqué car
on avait on avait obtenu le trône ni de
la scène du portugal tout ça où il y
avait une machine terrible approché du
ciel des pompiers alors on était obligé
à faire toutes les langues séquence est
alors le jeu qu'il a tourné après ses
seins sont dix pages de dialogues est
tous liés et avec fracas bella toujours
sur lui et il a dit oui
la veille c'est juste ce qu'il a dit
qu'il avait tué la veille mais comme
s'il avait tourné
la veille la même scène
étant est ce que là vous vous attendez à
une révélation dans le cinéma
international cette année où pensez
qu'on connaît à peu près tous les grands
talents ou qu'il doit toujours il peut
toujours intervenir un nouveau quelque
chose qui change la face du cinéma mais
je parle de crise le chômage parce que
l'unique façon de beille que ces prises
c'est de toujours d'espérer qu'ils
m quelqu'un d' et tourna et qui
renouvelle intérêts qui nous est le
langage du cinéma et ça vous semble
justifier en partie sans doute
l'existence de manifestations comme le
festival de cannes donc où la prochaine
fois que nous recevons ettore scola nous
aurons un parasol car sur cette terrasse
du carlton il faut dire que la chaleur
est un peu fatigant mais ça n'est pas
grave
ne nous plaignons pas nous avons reçu et
nous vous remercions monsieur ce que les
barreaux la nuit de varennes donc c'est
le premier film en compétition c'est la
journée scola la journée varin